or send in questions. Let's see if I can get that collected. Hopefully you'll be able to see your chatted in questions as well.
But a number of you sent in questions, so let's jump to those. I have to look up up my screen to read that.
Okay, I had what I suspect was Lyme disease several summers ago.
Blue-like symptoms, followed by a rash after the flu-like symptoms.
Lyme, a literate doctor, had a zoom call with me. I didn't test as I didn't think it would be accurate.
I was at an antibiotic for a month, took some oregano oil, not consistent for a couple weeks.
Also took your acute LX and chronic LX never completed the whole bottle.
What could I continue to do to help my immune system? I don't think I have symptoms other than the normal fatigue or lack of inhibition.
Okay, so if you know you had Lyme disease, so remember what Lyme disease is.
It's Boralia burgdorphy, also multiple colon infections can go along with it.
It comes from a tick bite, typically a deer tick in the, in there's three phases of Lyme disease.
There's the acute phase where that is defined as the bacteria is still in the blood or the tissues.
And it is fairly easily killed by using an antibiotic.
The problem is it could go into phase two, which is typically known as chronic Lyme.
Phase two, by my definition, is that it's, that the bacteria has gone inside of a cell.
So understand with bacteria getting in your body, they're looking to just replicate themselves and looking to, you know, raise a family.
So they're making lots of little baby bacteria. And they don't tend to do that in the blood quite readily.
Remember your blood is flowing a river of blood going through your body.
So it's not really easy to raise a family and we're going to live a river.
So they get into the tissues and your immune system is attacking them.
So whatever you have a bacterial infection or viral infection or anything else,
you elicited immune response to kill that infection.
So the bacteria are trying to stay alive.
The Lyme has multiple different ways to stay alive.
And I could find a lot of those through my books and on our website and some videos on our Lyme course.
But once a bacteria goes inside of a cell, this doesn't always happen.
The majority of people that get Lyme disease every single year, never take it antibiotic and their body is clear enough themselves.
It's just when any infection becomes more virulent, partly due to the strain, partly due to the health of your immune system at that particular moment of time.
That the bacteria starts to replicate quickly and now your immune system can't take care of it as well.
The bacteria can try to hide and try to protect themselves by going across a cell membrane and getting inside of a cell.
Now your immune system can't kill something that's inside of a cell.
So your immune system just kills things in the blood and kills things in the extracellular space.
So once a bacteria or anything gets inside of a cell, it's basically protected from your T cells and your macrophages and your natural killer cell response.
It's the immune side, the killer side of your immune system that's trying to kill that.
So to answer this question, if you got Lyme disease, it was correctly diagnosed, you received an antibiotic, you quite possibly could have killed everything.
You don't have any Lyme disease anymore.
If in a case of where it does get inside the cell, it still doesn't mean your body can't ultimately take care of it as your body tries to kill that bacteria.
That bacteria has to go outside of the cell to replicate and it can be killed by a healthy immune response.
And the person may have been sick, may have had symptoms like this person who asked the question to begin with.
And now they don't have any more Morelia bacteria in their body. It's not there anymore.
So they solve that problem. Whatever you have a bacterial infection in your body killed it or you used antibiotics to help your body kill it and it's gone.
You don't have the presence of an acute infection anymore. Well, quite as you don't have to worry about it.
But with some people, a small percentage of the people that get Lyme, that bacteria can cause other issues.
If it starts to replicate in the cell or goes outside of the cell and continues to replicate and then hides back in the cell again multiple, multiple times in your immune system is trying to kill it.
What happens with your immune system is that then you will create B cells or you'll have a B cell response or a TH2 response to your immune system.
That is the side of the immune system that makes antibodies and you'll actually make antibodies against Borrelium, which is fantastic.
You want to have antibodies against the bacteria so it can take the bacteria so that the killer side of your immune system can more readily kill that bacteria.
The problem comes in as when a bacteria continues to hide inside a cell, let's say it's in one tissue.
Let's just for an example use, let's say it's settled in your thyroid area.
So this happens over and over that you have this TH1, TH2 response in that area.
Well, you can begin to make antibodies against your own tissue.
So you can begin to make antibodies against your thyroid cells.
And once you make antibodies against self tissue, now you've moved into what I call phase three.
You basically moved into an autoimmune disease.
So another way to put it is you have an autoimmune disease caused by Lyme.
You have antibodies to self tissue because of Lyme disease of Borrelia or what I call phase three Lyme.
That's a whole different Bolognics, a whole different way you have to treat it.
You can't treat it now by stimulating the immune system because every time you stimulate your immune system you'll kill that which you have antibodies against.
You'll be killing self tissue.
I guess if I had a history, so what I did, so I had Lyme disease several times.
I got it antibiotic for it.
And I believe that I killed it that I didn't have any symptoms after I was able to destroy the bacteria.
So can you test four, do I still have the bacteria?
Yeah, you could do a PCR test to see four Lyme disease, to see if you have a presence of bacteria still.
If you do an antibody test for Lyme disease, if you have IgG or IgA antibodies, that's mainly past exposure.
You have to look and see if you have IgG antibodies that you have a current exposure, current infection.
But if you feel like you've killed it, you don't really have any symptoms from that.
We have to be careful not to blame all our current symptoms on a past disease.
And we see that a lot with people that have history of Lyme disease.
They say, you know, I have Lyme disease.
Well, what did you get it? Well, 10 years ago, when I still have Lyme disease, so they're still trying to find the magic killer substance nutrient out there that's going to kill this bacteria.
Well, at least nine times out of 10, those people don't have any current bacteria in their system.
Well, yes, I do, they'll argue.
I've been sick since I had that Lyme disease 10 years ago.
Well, that Lyme disease 10 years ago probably moved you to what's called phase three live.
You have antibodies to sell tissue.
That's really what's causing your symptoms.
Is this autoimmune disease?
Not the fact that you have present bacteria present in your system from 10 years ago.
It'd be very, very rare.
Again, nine plus times out of 10.
They have an autoimmune disorder from the cause from the bacteria back at that time.
And they're actually doing themselves more harmed by taking all these immune students.
So you have to be really careful with that.
I go into detail on our product Lyme course on that that explains that.
I go into detail somewhat in my books on chronic Lyme.
My autoimmune course goes into tremendous detail on how to actually treat that.
So if you have antibodies to sell tissue, how do you know that?
You have to do tests.
We have to test for that.
So there's different antibody tests out there that you could do through standard blood work.
Do you lose tests?
Those are called systemic antibody tests or systemic autoimmune diseases like an A and A tests and things like that.
Or if you want to get specific to specific tissue testing, you could do a Syrex lab panel.
Syrex array 5, Syrex array 7x, where you could get a specific test.
And whether you have, you know, to help diagnose what autoimmune disease you have if you do have self antibodies.
So to answer your question, I dig into further testing. That's what I would do.
I wouldn't you have to be careful when you have past exposure that to just throw immune stimulants at it.
Because you can be making yourself worse.
Digging into some further testing to figure out exactly what's going on.
If you have, it says you have normal fatigue and lack of inhibition.
The other can be some normal fatigue with, you know, everyday stress and just everyday issues with aging.
But if you feel like it's a little bit balanced more so than your friends or colleagues or family members, then you want to dig into some further tested.
You could contact your office and we could help you.
The next question, can one use things like the right machine or inference on us or PEMF if you're on different medications or cancer.
Does it interfere with the effectiveness of the cancer drugs?
The right machine and PEMF would not interfere with medications for cancer or cancer drugs or chemotherapy or radiation.
Saunas might.
Saunas increase your body temperature, increase your ability to detoxify and sweat.
You will detoxify through your skin with a sauna.
That's the whole purpose of doing a sauna.
If you increase your detoxification pathways with your out of medication, well, it can detox the medication.
So it's going to decrease the effectiveness of the medication you may need.
More of that medication.
You've got to be aware of that.
That's the same thing you've taken to homeless things to stimulate your detox pathways when you're doing a chemotherapy.
You could be detoxing the medication.
Or any medication.
So if you're doing any medication and now you looked into natural things and I'm going to really support detox pathways and start coffee animals and do these inference on us and do all this stuff that's going to be very helpful for me because it's good to say it's going to be good to help myself detox.
Makes a lot of sense.
But if you're out of medication, you do have to factor in that this ex dosage of the medication that was working for me doesn't seem to be working for me anymore because you are increasing the rate of detoxification.
If what you're doing is actually helping with your detox pathways, it's increasing the rate of detoxification through those pathways.
So you're going to increase the rate of detoxification of that drug.
Remember everything that you put in your body that you consume that you absorb that circulates in your body has to ultimately be detoxified through your liver phase one to three pathways.
If you're increasing the rate of function of those pathways, then it's supposed to figure that you are going to increase the rate of detoxification of those medications.
And you will lose effectiveness over time.
All those medications have a half-life of your body and you may want to talk to the prescribed doctor.
The rife is not doing that.
So the rife is actually if you're using the rife alongside chemotherapy who actually in my opinion helped the chemotherapy attack the cancer much more effectively.
I don't have any physical data other than just clinical observation to support that theory, but we just see that over and over again.
People that come to us that are doing chemotherapy, they found us because the chemotherapy was not working well.
We started with the rife and lo and behold the chemotherapy started working real well.
Now was it the chemotherapy that was still not working well and the rife was killing the cancer?
I don't know, but it just seems so coincidental that it's almost every single person that was doing chemotherapy prior to coming to us and getting a rife.
If they're chemotherapy started working better once they got the rife and maybe thought the chemotherapy is working better.
Maybe it's just the rife that was killing the cancer.
But I try to think through physiological processes when I try to decide what will work or what should work or what is working with any clientele.
And it just makes physiological sense to me that when you're hitting the cancer with its own frequency and you're causing it to vibrate, you're decreasing the waist layer around the cancer.
It's making it more available for medication like chemotherapy to attack it or even a natural approach to attack the cancer.
It's making it much easier for your own T cells and natural killer cells to attack the cancer.
So if you're doing chemotherapy and the chemotherapy is having a difficult time getting into the cancer, it's not going to kill it very well.
So if you could improve that, it's going to work better.
Certainly if you're going to do chemotherapy, you want it to work and you want to support every way you possibly can to make it work.
P-MF in my opinion will not affect your medication use in any way.
Somebody might argue that the MF really helps with detoxification.
I don't think so.
And the P-MF's real benefit is increasing cell charge.
The P-MF uses electrical frequencies where the rife uses light frequencies.
So the P-MF really isn't affecting the cancer, it's not killing the cancer.
But P-MF's are good tools. So they're great tools for somebody with serious disease.
They could help bring energy back to a cell because they help the cell charge.
And that's one of the things that is that is one of the problems with cancer is that you'll see a person's cell charge go down.
You can measure that cell charge with an instrument that measures what's called a phase angle that measures the impedance across the cell membrane.
And there's actually studies that show when you lose that cell charge, that cell membrane charge that impedance goes down the survivability of that patient goes down.
The MF can help improve that. So it can be very beneficial in that way.
Don't think that interferes with any medication.
Next question, what should I do about high blood calcium levels?
Well, I don't know anything about this person who's asking this question.
But high blood calcium, so if that's the only thing abnormal on your blood test,
and you don't have any known disease, you have to, it's like any other test you have to dig to why?
Why? What's going on?
So what's the most common cause of high blood calcium?
It's parathyroid tumor as the most cold cause.
So your parathyroid glands right up here, screen a hormone to help you get rid of calcium in your kidneys and retain calcium in your kidneys.
When you have high blood calcium, the most common cause of that is a tumor in the parathyroid gland.
And you need to get in right away and get that removed.
You just have to, it's not something to play around with.
I've seen multiple cases like this, just go in and get the surgery.
It's very simple, easy to do, surgery, typically all the patient, and you'll get that done.
With a person with a diagnosis of cancer, high blood calcium is typically indicative of metastatic disease to the bone.
So most metastatic cancers to the bone, when cancer metastasizes to the bone.
It's a breast cancer and it metastasizes to the bone.
It's typically going to be a lidic cancer, it's going to be a lidic lesion.
By that, I mean cancer erodes away the bone.
And by eroding away the bone, you're going to spill calcium into the blood.
You're going to have excess blood calcium like this.
I don't have cancer.
And I don't know what it is, I go to get a check, could be parathyroid.
It could be, you have primary bone cancer, primary bone cancer can be lidic or plastic.
And could result in high blood calcium.
Regardless, whatever you have abnormalities in your blood test, you should find out why.
And it's going to require some further testing.
I can't tell you how many people that I talked to on a weekly basis that they sent me their blood work.
And I go, okay, what did you do this two months ago?
Did you ever address this, this, this, this, nobody doctor talked about it.
But, okay, why would you run a blood test on somebody?
If you don't a, address the abnormalities correctly and be formulated plan to deal with those abnormalities.
And see, retest to see if you're playing it worked.
I, I just, I don't get it.
I have bad ones sometimes.
So, you see, lots of times with cancer patients with it.
They have an edemia and it's like, okay, what did, what did the doctor do about this edemia?
Nothing.
Well, this is, this, I can't even use this blood work.
It's six months old.
It's going to change drastically in that time.
We need to do more blood work and see what's going on now.
However, your blood work is a picture in type.
And, and it tell, it gives you clues on what could be going on.
So, we want to figure out what is going on.
And you have to dig to that reason why.
Question came in.
I began right feet eight years ago with the F117.
Three days in.
I felt much sicker 10 days in the old injury sites began.
Feel much worse than three months in a die off.
I cursed.
So, question is, when you, I think the question is because I know the person who asked this question was doing fantastic right now.
But when you start rifing for infection.
So, when you, when you use the right.
To kill an infection, especially a gram negative bacteria like.
The relia vermin orphy.
It kills quite quickly.
The right works.
And it's very evident when you have line disease that you use.
The right machine.
If you have the presence of a.
And then it is going to kill the bacteria.
And if it's a gram negative bacteria, it's going to elicit what's called lipopolysaccharides from the cell membrane.
And you're going to end up with what's called a herximer reaction.
So, herximer reaction is when.
You produce a lot of endotoxins in your body that could overwhelm the immune system in itself.
And it can make you feel really yucky.
It can make you feel like flu-ish fatigue.
You know, you just feel really lousy.
If that's the case, you need to slow down.
And whatever therapy you're using to make sure that you, you know, you can overcome that.
Because you can make yourself sick.
You have to slow down.
Now, I will say that.
Some people will say that they are hurt.
Their herxine.
It's short for herximer reaction.
It's very common term in the live community.
But they're not really experiencing a herximer reaction.
So, if you're killing directly with the right-fishing,
you're running Borrelia frequencies with the right-fishing, and you're herxine,
then that's a sign you have still the presence of the bacteria.
And by killing it off directly using the right, because the right-fishing stimulated immune response,
it's killing directly when it's killing live.
And you will, you know, produce a lot of endotoxins.
And the endotoxins produce when you kill a gram negative.
The bacteria are like the polysaccharides, which are going to make you feel ill.
So, that's a sign.
If you run the right, and you have a product live, and you're running live frequencies,
and you have a herximer reaction that is you had, or have, the presence of live bacteria still in your body.
So, then you've just got to slow down and go with your pace that you can to tell you get it up.
You've killed enough where you know you could run a longer program and you don't feel ill.
And now you can deal with the comorbidities of live disease.
But many people will take immune stimulants, they'll say,
why every time I take, you know, let's say, my straggleness, or my, you know,
might have had sea dose for my live disease, I herx, and then I have to back off for a couple of weeks.
And I do it again for a couple of weeks, and I herx, and I have to back off for a couple of weeks.
And these people were diagnosed maybe 10 years ago.
Well, the truth is, they may not have the presence of, back to, they're not really herxy.
They're not killing bacteria, producing endotoxins and feeling sick from that.
It's that they may be in phase three, they have antibodies to self tissue.
And every time they're stimulated in an immune system, response by taking a supplement,
an herbal, or a vitamin C, or a garlic, or something like that,
that is a direct immune stimulant.
Every time you stimulate your immune system, if you have self antibodies,
you're going to kill self tissue.
So this, quote, unquote, herx reaction that this person experiences is actually the symptoms of self tissue destruction.
So you have to be careful of that.
Again, how do you know that? You have to do testing, you have to run some labs.
Another question came in, so thankful to have begun 3D with you in 2016 by
a son that bought a F122 from you, too.
Okay. Well, thank you so much for that.
Well, I hope you're doing well and your son will do well with that, too.
I think it's good to have a right, but you have hope.
Even if you don't have cancer and you don't have lung disease,
it's a great tool to have to help, just to every day,
have a cough, or a cold, or have a feeling well, or have allergies,
or just talk about, just have a patient the other day that has prostate cancer.
He and his wife made a call with me because he has to go in and have MRI on his shoulder,
because he heard his shoulder he thought he had a torn rotator coffers, something like that.
And he's been in a sling, and he's been hurting so bad.
He's been taking pain medication, and he's tired of taking pain medication,
he's trying to figure this out, and I said, hey, you already have a right for your cancer,
run the accelerated healing program that could help with the folded,
jointed issues like that.
He did that, and this was two days ago, and his wife said, need a email.
Yesterday morning, he said, there's the first night he was able to sleep without pain,
and he stopped out of my throat, so he's very thankful.
So, a wife is a great tool to use for lots of other things.
Next question, what protocell formula is recommended for metastatic breast cancer?
Or does it depend on where the cancer has metastasized?
I have survived stage three breast cancer with protocell diet and detox methods.
My husband is a pharmaceutical doctor, and has recommended protocell to some of his patients as well.
My regimen in 2007 to 2012 was no supplement or food high in vitamin C.
I understand that you recommend if a person chooses to eat or take these between protocell dosages.
Is this a more recent change in your program?
We have a friend who has recently diagnosed with metastatic breast cancer
that is considering this treatment method as opposed to doing knee or chemo.
Okay, so for those who don't know what protocell is, protocell is a natural product that's used for cancers,
but it's an oxidizing agent.
So, I'll touch on this briefly, but you can find out more about antioxidants and oxidants on my blog.
So, go to www.cuttersclidic.com and search.
I just wrote an article recently.
What's it called?
Harnessed the...
Let me see.
I'm looking up the wall.
Because it's a good article.
She read it.
Harnessed oxidative stress to kill cancer.
That's today to the wall.
So, I just did it a couple weeks ago.
Harnessed oxidative stress to kill cancer.
What does that mean?
Okay, so you have...
Everybody's heard of antioxidants.
Have we taken more antioxidants?
Oh my gosh, we need to take more antioxidants.
Take more antioxidants.
Well, the truth is that you have oxidation that takes place.
And you have an antioxidation that takes place within your cells, within your tissues,
within your liver, within your body, all the time.
We can't get too hung up on that oxidative stress is all bad.
Because it's not.
Everything that happens in your body has to have a balance.
So, oh, oxidative stress causes this.
Oxidative stress causes this.
Well, that's true.
But oxidative stress is also produced in your body to kill bacteria,
to kill viruses, to kill microbes in your body.
Oxidative stress is produced as a side note in other metabolic activity.
And then you typically produce antioxidants to deal with that.
But we can easily get hung up on that.
Everybody needs to be taking antioxidants.
And the truth is, is that cancer patients who should really be careful in taking antioxidants.
And my mouth guy, right, that cancer patients shouldn't be taking antioxidants at all.
And why?
Because so cancer is cells that are in rapid replication.
And because they're in rapid replication, they're not replicating super healthy cells.
The cells are, the mitochondria of the cells are functioning, you know, real well.
Therefore, you're not making a lot of glutathione, which is your main intercellular antioxidant.
And cancer cells themselves are under a lot of oxidative stress.
So if you can picture it like that cell has a possible lethal dose level,
if you could put it on a graph, a lethal dose level of oxidative stress.
And if it reaches that lethal dose of oxidative stress, it's going to implode and die.
It's going to cause lysis of the cell and destruction of the cell.
Well, cancer cells are really close to that lethal dose.
A healthy cell isn't healthy cells producing glutathione, getting rid of oxidative agents,
reactive oxygen species, reactive nitrogen species, fairly effectively.
And this person is, that cell is staying fairly healthy.
Cancer cells, rapidly replicating, are not producing a lot of glutathione, are not getting rid of oxidative stress.
Because they're producing rapidly, they're producing more oxidative stress.
So they're real close to that threshold of lethal dose of oxidative stress.
Now, we can harness that.
So that's what chemotherapy is.
Well, this is the grudge that alternative doctors had against chemotherapy.
Here, comments like, chemotherapy is a poison.
Why would you put this poison in your body?
Okay, well, in true definition, chemotherapy is a poison because it's an oxidizing agent.
So, any poison is an oxidizing agent at a certain dose.
So, yes, we're giving an oxidizing agent to a cancer patient.
Well, why does that even make sense?
Why would you give a cancer patient a quote unquote poison?
It makes all the sense in the world from physiology.
Because you're dealing with a cell line, this cancer that is growing and growing and possibly metastasizing,
that is at close to threshold of lethal death of oxidative stress.
How can we just tip it over a little bit?
It helped that cancer cell die.
Well, we could give it chemotherapy.
That's how chemotherapy works.
So, we're going to give it just a little bit more lethal dose of oxidative stress, an oxidizing agent,
to hopefully tip that over and kill the cancer.
Well, the truth is that we could do that also with natural needs.
And I touch on four different nutrients in that article.
Melatone, Delta, Tokofriedol, Vitamin E, Selenium and Vitamin C.
At a certain dose.
So, all those things that I just mentioned would be considered.
If you looked at antioxidants, Vitamin E is an antioxidant.
Selenium is an antioxidant.
Melatone is an antioxidant.
Vitamin C is an antioxidant.
There's many, but I just touched on those four in that article.
But what has been discovered is that at a higher dose of those nutrients,
they actually work as oxidizing agents on cancer cells.
And interesting, they don't cause oxidation of healthy cells.
Kind of cool, huh?
So, higher dose melatonin, like typically you take three milligrams of melatonin to help you fall asleep at night.
Maybe six.
That's about the dose of melatonin that you would use.
But doses of 40, 60, 80, 100 milligrams of melatonin, even up to 200 milligrams of melatonin,
have found to be oxidizing to cancer cells.
And can be that tipping point to cause that extra level of oxidative stress in a cancer cell
to, for it to reach the lethal dose of oxidative stress caused down,
similar to what chemotherapy does.
Well, there's other nutrients that have been on the market for a number of years.
One of them is protocell.
That's an oxidized agent for cancer cell.
Leotro is another thing.
That's an oxidized agent for cancer cell, D17.
There's numerous oxidized agents for cancer cells that we use.
Now, I am said with some people, so we do cheek swab testing with our patients.
Some people test well for antioxidants as well.
So, I typically, if they test well for antioxidants, if they test for protocell,
then I have them take the antioxidants.
That's what this question is about between doses.
But really, for the most part, most of my patients, I do not recommend that they take antioxidants that have cancer.
Because you are untympically treating them with higher dose of those things,
or protocell, or B17, or something else that is an oxidizing agent,
so that we're hard to see that the same thing as chemotherapy.
And interestingly, studies were done on these things with a person being on chemotherapy too.
So it actually can help the chemotherapy work better as well.
So bottom line is, the question is, what protocell formula,
because there's two formulas of protocell, protocell 23 and protocell 50,
would you recommend for metastatic breast cancer?
Well, honestly, we test people for that, so we get a cheek swab test people for that.
In general, I think more with breast cancer, it'd be more formula 23 with prostate cancer,
it'd be more likely to be formula 50, but that's all I could say as far as in general goes with that.
But in general, too, with treating cancer anyway, you don't want to be an antioxidant.
Or if you're on an antioxidant like vitamin C as an antioxidant,
if you're taking it at a higher dose, it's an oxidizing agent.
So just be taking it at a higher dose, don't be taking it at a low dose vitamin C.
A question, thank you for all you do.
What are your thoughts and experience with bladder cancer?
Well, just like bladder cancer, just like any other cancer.
To me, every cancer is different, even if two brothers come in with bladder cancer.
Okay, we still treat them very differently.
We do a cheek swab, we test for what they need, and they could come up with a completely different protocol.
So everybody's unique in our book, so I don't like, here's the protocol for bladder cancer.
My book that doesn't really exist.
So we want to be as specific as possible and test them to see what they would need.
It could be totally different protocol for those two brothers.
As far as the right frequencies go, the right frequencies would be similar if not as exact same frequencies for bladder cancer.
So with any cancer, I just think, you know, obviously if you look at our website,
go to cuttersplinic.com, you'll see why we like the right, whether the right is what got me into helping people with cancer,
way back with the late 90s, and I just think you're just foolish not using the right machine.
While you're doing an oxidative stress, you know, protocol or while you're doing chemotherapy,
while you're doing whatever you're doing, I think the right is a great compliment to help whatever you're doing work better.
So contact us through that clinic, you can through that clinic website if you want.
Are there any topical things to do to help with benign tumors that are close to the skin surface,
or what else could someone use to try to get rid of a single solid benign tumor,
that is a clear morphic abnormal of the product.
So getting rid of solid tumors, so there's a difference between different tumors, but I'd tumors.
Some could be fluid filled, some could be solid tumors.
Can you get rid of solid tumors without doing surgery?
So I know a pleomorphic, add milk off the product lane is almost always going to be treated with surgery.
Is that a bad thing? I really don't think so.
What if somebody can't do surgery for whatever reason?
What are some other things to do?
Can you use topical things?
It's going to be very hard for a topical to get down to that.
I know people who have used topical things, something that's close to the surface and used DMSL as a driver over that thing.
So that is something that you could think of.
What would you use topically on a tumor like that?
Again, you would just try to kill that tumor.
That would be, without testing that, it would be really hard to say.
I can't really give you specifically what you would use for that.
We have used the right benign tumors with actually great success.
I first had a patient come to me and said they had a benign.
I think it was a giant cell tumor that was about, I think it was a 13-14 centimeters large of their abdomen.
I wasn't quite sure how it was going to work.
How the right was going to work.
But they had referred by a cancer patient.
I said, I don't know what this is going to work or not.
I wrote a program for it.
Which I think the last time I spoke there was down to three centimeters.
It's kind of just been staying at that.
It can work for a lot of different things.
That's one thing I would try if you were totally against surgery.
I do know the surgery for those are pretty simplistic as far as surgery is going in a very high success rate.
Next question.
Does all of the extract stimulate the immune system?
I have Hashimoto.
So I generally avoid immune system stimulants.
Why is person there?
Currently taking olive leaf for sinus problems.
My right is is flared up.
Any suggestions for my right is.
So yes, olive leaf extract is a direct immune stimulant.
It's considered a direct immune stimulant.
So again, when you have white, so some people listen to this or like,
what is this person talking about?
This person is wise.
So they know they have Hashimoto.
So Hashimoto is antibodies to the thyroid plant.
So if you have self antibodies, we need antibodies to any self tissue.
You have to be careful using herbal immune stimulants.
So you know, vitamin C, garlic, echinacea, olive leaf extract.
It falls into that category.
So that's a direct immune stimulant.
Why do you have to be careful of that?
Because every time you stimulate your immune system, you will kill that which you have antibodies against first,
which means you're going to destroy, in this case, your thyroid is playing.
So you have to be careful of that.
Now, can you use immune stimulants?
What can I never use immune stimulants if I have, you know, an auto,
have I have Hashimoto's?
No, I wouldn't say that.
In a cute case, so like, I got a really bad strep.
I don't need to take something.
You could take it for a few days.
So use it wisely though.
Don't stay on it for a long period of time.
I write this as inflammation.
What can you do about that?
Well, you got to find out why you have it.
Because if it's just irritation, from some external source,
is it an immune reaction because of an allergy?
You'll also, it's that oncology antibodies to differ by tissue.
So that's something you may want to look at and test it as well.
Remember, once you have antibodies to self-tissue like Hashimoto's,
it's really easy for you to start developing antibodies to other self-tissue.
That's why you have to be careful studying your immune response.
All right.
I'll get to some of the questions on the chat here.
What to do for a seven-year-old recently clinically diagnosed with alopecia,
either no symptoms besides minimal hair loss.
So, alopecia, again, other autoimmune issue,
go to, really, you should pay the 50 bucks to do my chronic disease at autoimmune course.
Because you have to know, so when you're treating an autoimmune disease,
I mentioned multiple times today you don't want to be stimulated in your response.
But then you also have to look for hidden things.
So, okay, well, I'm not taking any immune stimulators, so I'm going to be fine.
Well, are there other ways that you're stimulated in immune response?
Well, I don't know.
How?
Okay.
If you have antibodies to foods, every time you eat that food,
you're stimulated in immune response.
So, let's have antibodies to gluten.
Okay, that's a big one.
So, no, I'm completely gluten-free and dairy-free.
I mean, you're really good at diet.
Okay, well, still really good to do like a Syrex array 10.
Because you'll find out, oh my gosh, I did.
I have antibodies to almonds.
I drink almond milk every day, because I'm dairy-free.
Okay, every time you drink that almond milk,
you're stimulated in immune response, destroyed self-tissue,
possibly creating more antibodies to other self-tissue,
the secondary tertiary, you know, and so on,
diagnosis of different autoimmune disorders.
So, you have to find the triggers.
I cannot overemphasize that.
You have to find your triggers.
How do you find your triggers?
Well, I don't have money for testing.
Well, then you're going to have to do some digging
and put your Sherlock Holmes hammer.
The best way to find triggers is to do appropriate testing
for different antibodies, different food antibodies.
So, you can have triggers that are food source,
you can have triggers that are environmental source.
Hey, I have allergies that I have a hyperhistamine reaction
when I go outside of the spring.
That stimulates a TH-12 response.
And that's going to make my autoimmune disease worse.
So, you've got to figure out those triggers
to try to calm those things down as best as possible.
Well, this is very complicated.
What's very complicated?
It is very complicated.
People are looking for a doctor that just says,
here, all you need to do is take this magic supplement
and you're going to be all better.
But I'll tell you, most people have been to 40 doctors
that have done these magic supplements of $80,000
for the supplements, and they didn't work,
and they got now recovered for the $1,000 supplements,
and they don't work.
Because it's a little more complex than that.
So, to take that course,
I think that will help you understand that.
Hi, any suggestions for low or below normal blood levels
of values of iodine?
Fair to levels are okay.
But okay, like I said before,
any test you do have low iodine,
so I should just take iodine, right?
No, no.
You've got to figure out why you have low iodine in the first place.
Is your MCD, your MCHC,
or your other anaemic markers
in the functional low range or high range?
Is it a B12 deficiency?
Is it iodine loss from bleeding disorder?
Is it iodine loss from excess bleeding during periods?
You've got to figure out why you have low iodine?
It could be genetically related,
it could be, there's just a ton of reasons.
So, you have to be, every time you do a test,
and there's an abnormal value.
So, if you do a blood test,
there's like, you know, you tested 50 things on that blood test,
and there's four of them that are abnormal.
You have to ask the question, why?
So, why is this off?
And it's very rarely as simple as,
you just need to take some iodine.
You're just going to be okay.
If you do have primary iodine deficiency,
you have to ask the question, why do you have that too?
Is it because you're not absorbed iodine?
Is it because you have a damaged gut?
Is it because you're screening it?
Is it, it's just a lot of things you need to cover.
I hate to be such a pest about this,
but don't you want somebody that's going to dig to figure this out?
Instead of just throwing stuff at the wall and opening sticks?
Sorry.
What are some holistic ways to deal with HPV?
That's H-A-H-C-C really helped.
Again, I would,
it's not as simple as that.
You know, I know.
I've gotten a lot of comments about what's your solution for this or that?
And I would honestly suggest you make an appointment with me,
and we dig just some, look at your other blood values as well.
We just had her go, this must be referring to the seven-year-old.
She said her go gluten-free, dairy-free,
and eight,
and are giving her vitamin C, D3, K2, and a probiotic.
Well, I would not give her the vitamin C for sure.
Maybe we shouldn't be doing the supplements in case it stimulates
an immune response like you said.
Well, the vitamin D3 is an immune regulator,
so don't worry about that.
The vitamin K2 should be fine.
The probiotic should be fine.
The vitamin C is definitely a immune stimulator.
With an autoimmune disease, you do not want to be...
I mean, it's just general rule.
We've got any autoimmune disease.
You can't be out immune stimulants.
Like I said,
in acute situation,
you can be out of partial term.
Any autoimmune disease, general rule, no immune stimulants.
So, we go off of that.
Good first start to be gluten-free, dairy-free.
The only issue that you have to watch out for is that, you know,
you go gluten-free, you start eating gluten-free products.
Like here, I'm going to eat this gluten-free bread because it's stuck.
You know, it doesn't have any gluten in it, so it'll be good for me.
Probably there's got a whole bunch of other things in it that you might actually have antibodies against too.
So maybe it's the certain other kind of flower or all the flower or whatever it is.
So you won't know unless you test.
So many times people go gluten-free thinking,
well, that's going to be my problem.
And it just brings up other problems.
So just be aware of that in your journey.
But at some point in time, you may want to do a CyRex panel.
I know this person's only 10.
Also, you know, it may not be the food itself.
It could be chemicals in the food.
It could be pesticides and herbicides.
I know a lot of people that have gluten-sensitivities and gluten antibodies,
but they can eat French flour just fine.
What's the deal with that?
Well, definitely the gluten structure,
the gleaned structure in the French flour is different than the flour that we're exposed to.
But also, it's not GMO organic.
You know, that can make a big difference.
I know people that can eat organic gluten, foods, and not anything that's not organic.
So those are the,
that's the Sherlock hat that you have to put on with your dealing with fighting your different triggers.
My 77-year-old mother recently had triple bypass surgery and was diagnosed with hemicromatosis.
Her GP and cardiologist suggest there's no connection.
What are your thoughts on hemicromatosis?
I would agree that there's quite possibly no connection.
So hemicromatosis is quite common.
We used to diagnose hemicromatosis a lot when we did a lot of genetic.
There was a time in history where we were one of the only clinics that were doing genetic,
full genetic, good genetic workups.
I was doing, gosh, multiple a day.
And I would diagnose hemicromatosis because there's a gene for that.
Okay, so the reason why I personally have hemicromatosis is because of a genetic variant.
And tell people that they need to deal with that,
give them some natural ways to deal with that.
But almost nobody knew they had it.
So it rarely brings symptoms.
So that's not uncommon.
And it could be completely unrelated to the need for the triple bypass surgery,
which was blocked arteries, which I would be more suggestive looking at.
Of course it had a bypass surgery.
You know, you have damaged arterial walls.
And then you go what damage the arterial walls is at high polycystine levels.
That was never checked.
Was this person never getting blood tested?
Was it age quite low, right?
That was never diagnosed, never investigated.
Was it product life?
Was it heavy metals?
Those are your three biggies for.
For pitothelial disorder.
Which is what we're talking about there.
You said it's called a Cyrex panel to do with seven-year-old.
You said is there any other testing blood work?
Yeah, so I'm just I'm just throwing that out there.
I'm not your doctor.
So if you go on our product disease at autoimmune site,
you'll see the possible testing.
Again, talking over with your doctor.
Otherwise, you could make an appointment on our clinic or more specific things to do.
Next question that was sent in.
Can you take protocell along with some chemotherapy drugs and.
And.
A robotic inhibitors for a metastatic breast cancer.
Horrible receptor.
Her too positive.
Her too negative breast cancer.
And that's to the abdomen.
Yes, you can.
So again, protocell again.
It's totally different person.
I asked this question.
It's kind of odd to get two protocell questions.
It's not both.
What protocell is.
So I write about protocell in my book.
And I think I actually interviewed.
The maker of protocell for my first edition.
I can't remember.
That was about 12 years ago.
But yes, you can take protocell with the robots.
The only thing.
The key with therapy is.
As I oxidize the agent as well.
Cell will only calculate that.
But that's protocell interferes.
We're all in case of inhibitor, which.
We'll take a hitter block.
Or more.
No, it doesn't at all.
You can take it at that cell.
There's no issue with this.
And you share cases with hormone receptor.
Positive her to breast cancer.
I can't really share cases.
Breast cancer is probably the most kind of cancer we see.
And we have.
There's also that.
Again, everybody's different.
Everybody's unique.
So when we do testing.
Again, you're going to have two twin sisters with the exact same cancer.
They're protocell.
They test completely different.
From a nutritional dietary.
But.
But every day should be right as well.
So.
Okay. Well, thanks for being on today.
I'm.
Let's see if we got a couple more questions here.
Absolutely.
Thanks.
Thanks for being on.
Thanks for asking questions.
Remember, try to go and ask your question before the class.
If you possibly can go to holistichealthour.com.
You'll see all our recordings of all our past classes too.
And.
That's a great job of breaking the doubt.
I don't know to see if it's topic you might want to listen to.
I don't.
So I want to listen to.
Somebody like me for an hour, but you tolerated it well.
So each one of you gets a gold star and a cookie just asked us to.
For your cookie.
And remember.
And.
And if you have other questions that aren't on that, please go to cluttersplitic.com.
I don't know.
We have well over a thousand blog posts and a really good search engine on that.
To search.
So you just go to that search bar.
You can search any topic.
We either have a page that discusses it or a blog post that discusses lots of different stuff.
So also go to videos.
Cutters.
Cut.
And our YouTube channel, which has well over thousands of videos on it as well.
So all right.
Thanks so much.
And we will talk to you next week.
And wish you guys all the blessings.
And we'll probably pray for all of you.